John: Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday.
I landed in Addis Ababa after a thirty hour
journey, met up with Bridget from the Gates
Foundation, and drove into the city where
I got some desperately needed and delicious
Ethiopian coffee, shopped for a bit at a local
market to get Henry this Ethiopia soccer jersey,
and then went to visit Yekatit 12 Hospital.
Hank, Ethiopia is one of the poorest countries
in the world.
Most people live without electricity or running
water, most fields are tilled by animal-drawn
wooden plows, and the shortage of basic services
can be overwhelming.
For example, the smallest hospital in my hometown
of Indianapolis has eight neonatologists.
In Ethiopia, a nation of ninety million people,
there are seven.
One of the first was Doctor Mulualem Gessesse.
So, to get to the Yekatit 12 neonatal intensive
care unit, you walk on plywood over standing
water that smells of sewage.
And then, up the stairs to the NICU.
Doctor Gessesse and her nurses have to be
very inventive.
For instance, they use the oxygen tanks, that
you see here, combined with tubing and water
to create a kind of C-Pap machine that keeps
premature babies' lungs inflated.
They don't have respirators or real C-Pap
machines, which Doctor Gessesse cites as among
her many critical needs.
But still, she's been very successful.
In the past few years, her ward has gone from
treating a couple hundred babies per year
to more than two thousand.
This little girl had to stay in the dark while
being treated.
Dr Gessesse: We suspect tetanus because she
has spasms.
I asked Doctor Gessesse several times about
her choice of specialty.
Dr Gessesse: So that we continue 24 hours.
John: [speaking to Dr. Gessesse] So why do
you choose to do this then?
Eventually she answered me.
Dr. Gessesse: My concern is for the Ethiopian
newborns.
John: Hank, twenty years ago, more than fifteen
percent of children who were born in Ethiopia
died before the age of five.
Today, it's less than seven percent.
Child mortality is falling faster in Ethiopia
than in the world overall, and it's much lower
than it is in far richer countries.
How has this happened?
Well, I'm obviously no expert, but one, Ethiopia
is serious about health, and two, organizations
like the Gates foundation and Save the Children
are helping Ethiopians execute an Ethiopian
health strategy rather than trying to impose
a strategy upon them.
Like, take Kangaroo Mother Care.
When preterm babies are well enough, they
live in the hospital for weeks or months with
their moms, getting constant skin-to-skin
contact.
The babies and moms are together in the hospital
24/7, and studies have shown that this leads
to better brain development, lower infection
rates, and better weight gain.
It's cheap, it works, and when you make a
small investment in these babies' lives now,
they have a far better chance of growing up
to have healthy and productive adulthoods.
But Dr. Gessesse also told me stories of failed
outreach, as when a dozen C-Paps arrived from
a charity, all of them adult-sized, and none
of them of use to her.
We have to listen to each other.
Hank, I've found humans to be extraordinarily
generous within their social networks, like
think of how quickly we support friends and
colleagues in need.
But lack of access to like, Tumblr and YouTube
makes most people living in absolute poverty
totally voiceless in our online world, and
inevitably we begin to imagine their problems
as others, as things that don't happen to
us.
If OUR kids were dying of malaria and diarrhea,
if dozens of OUR babies were dying for every
one that gets access to a jerry-rigged C-Pap
machine, we wouldn't stand for it!
But the thing is, these ARE our kids.
OUR world is also VERY LITERALLY their world.
Oh, and I did get to hang out with Bill Gates
who is brilliant, and I overcame my tremendous
fear of heights to fly in a helicopter with
him, and I will talk about all that stuff
in the coming weeks.
But for now let us just pause to be grateful
to Dr. Gessesse, who has quietly and unassumingly
saved the lives of thousands of babies.
Our babies.
As she told me, I have many children.
Only two biological, but many children.
Hank, I'll see you on Friday.